العربية سيكون اسهل من اضفاء
شمعة اذا سحبت الولايات المتحدة
ايديها منها وان قطعت يد
الامريكان فمرحبا بالسلام.
واشنطن تبتز العرب فتبدأ حربا
وتنهي اخرى. اعداء الامس هم
اصدقاء اليوم نعم ها هم يلتقون
ليجنوا ثمار لتجد واشنطن نفسها
وحيدة امام عالم متعدد الاقطاب.
فانسحبت من العراق وقد اكثرت فيه
الدمار وتركت افغانستان لتلاقي
مصيرها بعد ان يأست منها وعرفت
انها تضع فيها اكثر مما تجني.
وراحت تنهب الثروات السورية
لتتسع شهيتها وتطرق ابواب اليمن
وقبل ان تطرق باب اليمن يجب ان
تأخذ رشفة من النفط الليبي. نعم
خلافات العربية سادة بين صب
الزيت على النار ومعالجة الجراح
القديمة ولكن كما يقولون لكل افة
افة. لتشتعل حرب روسيا واوكران.
امريكا سيدة العالم لقد داس
الكرملين على طرف فستانها ولم
يعتذر فاشتعلت الحرب. الصين
وروسيا وامريكا وحلف الناتو صراع
العمالقة يا سادة. امريكا ترشق
روسيا بالعقوبات ليلفظ الروسي
انفاسه الاخيرة ولكن الحكمة
الصينية تقطع الاوردة الامريكية.
الحياد ثم الحياد واكررها ثم
الحياد. نحن لن نمتدح روسيا وهي
التي كذلك قتلت الكثير من
المدنيين في سوريا بطيرانها ولن
نلمع الصين التي سجنت وعذبت اكثر
من احد عشر مليون مسلم في الصين
ونقصد مسلمي الايجور. هيا لنبدأ
رحلتنا. اطفاء الحروب العربية.
الولايات المتحدة تضع ملحها على
الجراح العربية منذ القدم.
وعندما قامت الحرب بين عراق صدام
والكويت اوعزت واشنطن لدول
الخليج بالوقوف ضد صدام مع تأليب
بعض الدول العربية لهذا الحلف
للقتال في جبهة واحدة مستغلة
الخلافات العربية لتوسع الشرخ
اكثر من المساعي الامريكية لم
تحقق هدفها المطلوب. السياسة
الامريكية يقولها هيا لنتحجج
باسلحة الدمار الشامل والاسلحة
المحرمة في العراق ولنبدأ بالغزو
ونحقق اهدافنا. مهلا مهلا مهلا
لنفكر قليلا. هنا زعيم كوريا
الشمالية يمتلك النووي ويقولها
في العلن انا امتلك اسلحة محرمة.
فاذا ارادت امريكا الحرب فمرحبا
بها. وهناك ايران تبادل امريكا
نفس الشعور. هي تعلم جيدا اذا
تصادمت مع تلك الدول فلن تتردد
لثانية واحدة باستخدام تلك
الاسلحة المحرمة. امريكا كانت
تعلم ان العراق لا يمتلك اي
اسلحة نووية لتباشر بالغزو ولكن
لا بد من شركاء لكي تشعل شموع
حفلتها الخبيثة. ونقصد هنا حلف
الناتو ليبدأ المخرج الامريكي
بانتاج فيلم رعب نووي العراقي
للعرب. صدام لن يتردد بقصفكم
صدام يمتلك اسلحة محرمة. العرب
يقولون لامريكا اذا فما هو الحل?
ترد امريكا هنا نبدأ بالثور
الاسود ونقصد العراق الذي كان
يمتلك اقوى جيش عربي والرابع
عالميا. ليبدأ الغزو الامريكي
للعراق بحجة اسلحة الدمار الشامل
ويا له من عذر اقبح من ذنب كما
يقولها العرب انتهى الاحتلال ولم
ينتهي دماره. الخراب مستمر بلاد
الرافدين. وقفت الصين وروسيا على
الحياد فليس كل ما يلمع ذهبا
وليست كل الحروب متاحة لخوضها
تجنب الروس والصينيون الوقوف ضد
عدو عراقي لمعرفتها انها حرب
جائرة ظالمة. ولان لكل حرب نهاية
فها قد انتهى الاحتلال الامريكي
للعراق مع اعتراف امريكي بعدم
وجود الاسلحة التي تشكل تهديدا
للمجتمع الدولي فهل ان يتم صرف
هذا الاعتراف والاعتذار في
البنوك ايها الامريكان جنحت
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
للصلح في العراق لكن صلحها كان
بالانسحاب مع الاعتراف بالخطأ
فقط دون تعويض او حوار وكانهم
يحكمون في الغاب. يا للعجب! ترك
الامريكان العراق لكنهم لم
يتركوا ثرواته وسيطروا على النفط
بحجة حمايته من ولكن الرياح تأتي
بما لا تشتهي السفن. وبينما
انشغلت الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية بكيفية الحفاظ على
النظام العالمي الاحادي بتركيزها
على كيفية محاصرة الصين وروسيا
من خلال سياسة الاحلاف. الصين
تبدأ بتحريك ورقة العراق وذلك
بدخولها باسهم كثيرة في شركات
النفط العراقية باكثر من ثمانية
وثمانين مليار دولار. نعم. الصين
تتودد للعراق والامريكان يضغطون
على الحكومة العراقية لرفض تلك
العقود. ليحسم القلم العراقي تلك
المعركة وعلى نفس الطبق السياسي.
لن نبتعد كثيرا لنجد انفسنا في
ليبيا وهي البلد التي سال لعاب
الامريكان حولها. حيث استحوذت
ليبيا على اهتمام واشنطن لتبدأ
بصب الزيت على نار الليبيين.
والهدف من هذا كله منع روسيا من
تأسيس بحرية وجوية في سرت
والجفرة. وبسياسة علي وعلى
اعدائي ها هي حروب ليبيا الى
اليوم يتصاعد دخانها. اما في
سوريا وبعد حرب دامت لاكثر من
اثنتي عشرة سنة بين قوات النظام
السوري وبين الطرف المعارض الجيش
السوري الحر. امريكا تضع غشها في
حقول النفط السوري مستغلة وضع
الحرب لتبدأ بحرب النفط السوري.
العادة روسيا والصين تتدخلان
والهدف قطع الشريان السوري عن
الجسد الامريكي. بوتين يجمع
تركيا والتي تمثل طرف الجيش
السوري الحر كونها داعما
استراتيجيا لهذا الطرف. ثم يأتي
ببشار الاسد ليقول هيا لننهي
الخلاف ولنطفئ الحرب ليس حبا في
سوريا صراحة بل الهدف هو ما بعد
الصلح. ونقصد اجتثاث القوات
الامريكية من حقول النفط عندها
سيقول السوريون لامريكا باي باي
الى غير رجعة. واما اليمن فهو
يعاني من الامر ذاته حيث دخلت
امريكا على خط حرب اليمن
والسعودية وزادت من نار الحقد في
الخصومة. والهدف هي تلك الثلاثين
مليار دولار التي كانت تصرفها
السعودية شهريا من اجل حرب اليمن
وشراء الاسلحة. فاذا هدأت الحرب
اليمنية السعودية امريكا تحرك
ورقة ايران كما كانت تفعل مع حرب
الخليج وصدام. ليهرع الطرف
السعودي لشراء الاسلحة الامريكية
كي يعزز من قوة دفاعه خوفا من اي
حرب مستقبلية مع ايران. ها هنا
كالعادة تدخلت الصين وروسيا
وجماعة الاصدقاء الاعداء في
طاولة واحدة ايران والسعودية. من
كان يتخيل ذلك لينتهي الامر
بعناق حار متناسين كل تلك الحروب
والفتن زرعتها امريكا في اليمن
دخلت عمان كوسيط ونجحت بايقاف
الحرب اليمنية لقرابة سنة.
ليقولها ابناء خمنئي وسلمان.
وداعا لامريكا ولتنسوا كل تلك
الصفقات التي وقعناها معكم
وسنشتري اسلحتنا من روسيا والصين
ان اردنا. نظام العالم الجديد.
النظام القديم يتغير. وقائعه
الجديدة اخذة في حلفاء الولايات
المتحدة في الشرق الاوسط لا
ينضمون الى العقوبات المفروضة
على روسيا ويشككون في الدوافع
الامريكية لمعاقبة موسكو بادوات
مثل تحديد سقف لاسعار صادرات
نفطية او تخفيض الانتاج ما يؤكد
النفوذ الروسي في المنطقة.
محاولات الصين وروسيا الجدية
لملء الفراغ الذي تركته الولايات
المتحدة في الشرق الاوسط كثير.
لتكون الصين الدولة في شراء
النفط السعودي والخليجي بشكل عام
فلا تستغرب اذا قالت السعودية
والخليج لامريكا في يوم ما ويجب
ان تغادر قواعدكم العسكرية من
ارضنا فكل الاتفاقيات العسكرية
ملغية لتحل محلها روسيا والصين.
وينبغي ان نقولها صراحة. ان
الصين وروسيا ليسا ملائكة ايضا.
والصين ظلمت وطغت وتجبرت على
مسلم الايجور الذين يقدر عددهم
باحد عشر مليون بين قتل وتشريد
وتعذيب ويا لها من قسوة من اصحاب
العيون الضيقة. واما روسيا
فاستخدمت اسلحة لا يجوز
استخدامها في حرب سوريا. ومشاهد
اسقاط البراميل الحارقة لم تغب
عن الاذهان ليروح ضحيتها الكثير
من الارواح من المدنيين. لتلحق
بهما تركيا والتي لا زال الثروات
السورية من النفط والتحف والاثار
مبررة ذلك بمحاربة الاكراد
المتطرفين. لكننا لن نظلم تركيا
وسنوفيها حقها حيث اوت الاراضي
التركية اكثر من ثلاثة ملايين
ونصف المليون لاجئ سوري. بمجهود
يذكر فيشكر لكن فلتوقفوا عمليات
نهب يا احفاد عثمان. ولتعيدوا ما
سرقتموه. نحن لن نقف مع اي طرف
فجميعهم كما ذكرنا انفا ليسوا
ملائكة وليسوا رسلا كي يعصمهم
الله من الوقوع في الغلط. ولكن
امريكا تنال نصيب الاسد من ذلك
الظلم الذي لحق بالعرب. عندما
تبدأ شمس قوة عظمى كالولايات
المتحدة بالغروب سرعان ما تظهر
الاقطاب الاخرى قوتها ليبدأ عالم
متعدد الاقطاب. لكنه عالم اقرب
للصلح والسلام وابعد عن الحرب
والصراع يا سادة.